le principe est simple c'est un jeu
japonais vous allez vous mettre cette
élastique qui est là autour de la tête
proche du nez les avantages quand on est
animateur c'est qu'on est pas obligé
tester voici voilà voilà bien vous avez
cassé par équipe de trois accords ça va
être chronométrés les bus et de manger
ce petit bonbon accord j'invite nos bas
justement pas à petit bonbon d'accord
un drame à lui sa carence à la montée
merci à marolles donc celui enfin
l'équipe qui va le plus vite
ok remporte la partie d'accord c'est
trois d'un coup non mais non chaque
morfales et on gagne quoi mais on est
allés en reconnaissance alors quand je
vois le jeu finalement j'ai gagné
[Applaudissements]
alors isabelle voulait commencer
d'accord je vais bien attention la vidéo
placé chérie fm en place évitant
attention attention à l'alcool bien le
truc sous le titre
attention attention qu'est ce qu'elle
est photogénique
[Rires]
3 2 1 go
j'ai tissé le marié
[Applaudissements]
il a trouvé ça va aller moi j'en mange
pas mais ça revient au maître chez nous
j'allais le creusot non j'ai coupé a
bien sûr je pouvais tourner évidemment
joueurs commencent à moi mes joueurs au
chômage ont ouvert des comptes et
ressorte à leur remettre nos dans 3 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoutez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc vous avez mis 55 secondes pour
s'accorder le bleu manger elle ne
mangeait pas les vases à bouche et la
manger
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dans la tendance qu'ont les sondés du
bombardier vous les mangez moi j'ai pas
baver dessus
j'avais des bombes action j'espère alors
que monsieur est dans la rue j'avais
acquis mon rôle a dit on fera mieux eh
ben mon vieux
attention les garçons mettez-vous en
place on armés d'épées bernard m'a
appris comment vous défini d'un jardin
parce que roger waite l'ordre on va bien
mais on a gagné on va prendre en
commision musique raï et là attention
j'ia tu seras milieu très aisé mange et
on attend chatons katusha mais qu'est ce
que tu poses de ce programme
débauché
[Applaudissements]
c
allez
technique way
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
m les éléments sont contre j'espère ça
tourne ça vous a alors
dysfonctionnements attention quelle
pièce ouais
[Applaudissements]
si j'aurais vu les gars sont vos amis 48
secondes
si on arrête chef sans que ça vous donc
les garçons 48 secondes et fille et
fille 50 55 55
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]